[Music]
this scene is one of the most iconic
moments in inception
because the brilliantly choreographed
fight happens on the walls and ceiling
of a hotel hallway
and room but it's only one
in a long line of these types of shots
from royal wedding to high school
musical 3
to ariana grande's high concept music
videos
hollywood has been putting actors on
walls for decades
but how do they do it we talked to the
team behind one of the most recent
examples of this type of scene
zendaya's trippy drug-induced walk
through a house party in the pilot of
hbo's euphoria
to see how these scenes are shot and how
they took things a step further
[Music]
the basic concept behind getting a
character to walk on walls
and ceilings is by building a motorized
set
and having a camera fixed in place to
follow the room's 360 degree movements
in sync an actor moves on the surfaces
inside the set
carefully hitting their marks so they
don't injure themselves
keep in mind that the actors are always
working with gravity so their feet will
be on the ground
even if the ground happens to be the
ceiling and when the camera is fixed in
one place on the rotating set
all the viewer can see is the character
moving as opposed to the entire room
which would look different if the camera
were not attached
the technique is believed to have been
pioneered when fred astaire wanted to
dance all over a room in 1951's royal
wedding
the set was built inside of a steel
rotating circular structure
back then to create the effect from a
camera fixed in place
cinematographer robert plank strapped
himself
and his camera to an ironing board at
the base of the set
allowing plank to capture the exact
rotating actions of the room
while the actor was free to dance right
side up a stairs jacket over here
had to be sewn down and these curtains
were actually made out of
wood to ensure that everything stayed in
place
stanley kubrick showed this type of
setup could be used to imitate
life in space in 1968's 2001 a space
odyssey
[Music]
the rotating centrifuge set allowed the
audience to see the world like an
astronaut living in zero gravity the
filmmakers were
able to show somebody eating upside down
simply by gluing the food to an actor's
fork
but shooting 2001 showed how difficult
it is to bring
lights into a set that is in motion so
for the most part
all the lighting inside the centrifuge
had to come from strip lights attached
to it along the walls
some hidden and some visible if the
camera angle was wide enough
now jump to 1986 royal wedding director
stanley donnan would repeat the trick he
helped pioneer when he directed the
music video
for lionel richie's aptly named dancing
on the ceiling
they had a motor powered set for richie
and a few others to dance on
and the action was captured by a remote
controlled camera
meaning the cinematographer didn't need
to be harnessed into the set
the dancers were actually on a
stationary set where the floor was
designed to look like a ceiling
and they flipped the camera upside down
creating the illusion that they were
dancing on a real
ceiling then they used something that
didn't exist during freda stairs time
a blue screen to bring this together
with the image of richie and his band
dancing on the floor
bringing this genre of scene to a new
level by showing people standing on
two parts of a room at the same time
euphoria would find another way to do
just that
but we'll get there shortly even with
new technological innovations
the basics of this technique continued
to power dream sequences
and musical numbers in everything from
poltergeist
to a nightmare on elm street to high
school musical 3.
then 2010's inception created a scene
the audience would never forget
getting the illusion right now required
multiple sets
a horizontal one that rotated 360
degrees
a vertical one where the actors could be
lifted up by wires
and a trolley rig that moved the actors
around
despite all the cgi tools available at
this time
director christopher nolan took a
practical route shooting a fight scene
in an environment that was constantly in
motion
and it wasn't just one camera operator
with one camera attached to the set
they instead employed multiple camera
setups one of those cameras was fixed in
place
on the ground according to actor joseph
gordon levitt
this made it look like they were
fighting on every surface of the room
but without the audience seeing the room
itself spin
another camera was attached to a techno
crane which was not locked into place
but moved more independently in the
years to come
the general illusion was always
practical but cgi
allowed for new opportunities in the no
tears left to cry
music video ariana grande walks through
a rotating room
and falls through a crumbling wall into
another set
in reality the set was turned at just
the right moment so it looks like she is
falling through a wall
and not the floor she jumped out of one
of the set's open
ends which was later turned into a
crumbling surface
fast forward to 2019's euphoria which
added
even more twists to the technique
a few factors made this shoot a big
challenge
the camera couldn't just stay in one
place as it had to follow rue
who was played by zendaya down the
hallway think back to royal wedding
where the shot was always based on the
fact that there's one camera that
doesn't ever move
rotating with the set there are multiple
people in this sequence
and most importantly while roo defies
the laws of gravity the people around
her
do not basically this scene follows two
centers of gravity as opposed to just
one
to pull this off the show's visual
effects supervisor
david van dyke worked with pixomondo's
nat
fong tran you know it was literally a
science practice that we had to figure
out
3d models created by the vfx team helped
the crew
adjust the size of the set before
building it this set was actually a
recreation of a hallway from a real
house where they filmed the entire house
party scene
meaning it needed to match the actual
location ending with a staircase
and starting with this bathroom because
the room
doesn't start spinning until rue exits
the bathroom
they had to attach a motionless set to
the revolving one
on top of that the doorway between the
two sets
was too small for the alexa 65 camera
and crane to
fit and follow rue down the hallway
their solution
was to build the bathroom on a platform
this platform would split
and move out of the way once roos
stepped off of it
and into the revolving area allowing the
large camera
and prime lens to push through and like
with 2001
lighting a scene like this is difficult
so the shot was primarily
lit up with these ceiling lights that
were naturally a part of the set
to maintain the two separate
gravitational pulls
some of the background party goers were
strapped into the floor of the set
now no decision on a rotating hallway
can be spontaneous or random because the
actors were locked into place
the crew had to think specifically about
where they were placed in the revolving
room
look at the background and you will see
two people on the left wall two people
on the right wall
and two people in the back that is no
coincidence according to van dijk that's
because
weight had to be evenly distributed as
much as possible
you have kind of balanced people on both
sides okay so that it has a nice even
rotation and when shooting one of these
scenes it's crucial to watch out for any
element that could potentially give away
the whole trick
for instance for extras that had longer
hair there was the risk that their hair
would fall
up when they were completely upside down
according to van dyke
the crew actually put extra hairspray in
their hair to keep it in place
anti-gravity hair is not gonna look good
there were a lot of other possible tells
that had to be accounted for
this table over here with beer bottles
on top of it had to be bolted down
tight recall that same thing was done
for
all the furniture a stair danced around
in addition to the extras who were
strapped down
the show wanted to have a few people
walking behind roe
but they couldn't just have them on set
walking in a straight line
it was just impossible to have them
roped in
with the rotating set those would need
to be
shot as a separate pass so that they can
walk on the actual
normal floor with the normal gravity to
do this
they built a new version of the hallway
that didn't rotate
and filmed a few extras walking down it
this new shot needed to imitate the
exact
same movements as the revolving room so
the extras could be seamlessly added
into the primary shot
we have to recreate that same exact
camera motion so we cannot have like
another take that has a completely
different camera performance
it was much more advanced than just
holding a camera upside down
for the non-spinning set they used a
motion control camera which was
programmed to run alongside the extras
and imitate the first camera's moves to
a t and while this set didn't move
it still needed to appear as if it was
spinning to achieve that effect they had
to
inverse the hallways rotation and
incorporate that into the motion control
camera's movements
this was helpful because they were hard
moves to imitate
manually and they needed to be precise
the first couple you see
here is moving on an angle and this
extra was completely
upside down each plate had proper blank
spaces
taped off for where extras would stand
and sit allowing for these
other extras to then be composited
seamlessly into the shot
it's all quite a long way from the blue
screen effect and dancing on the ceiling
put all these elements together and you
have the convincing effect of zendaya
walking on walls as the surroundings
around her
remain normal sometimes creating an
amazing
sequence for the screen means borrowing
from hollywood history
and that's when those techniques evolve
into something fresh
each iteration might become more and
more ambitious
but nothing would be possible without
what came before it
fred astaire danced on walls so zendaya
could stumble on them
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
episode of movies insider
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
did we leave off any of your favorite
scenes of characters walking on walls
let us know in the comments
[Music]